here's what i say here's what i even
have a seven-figure domain name picked
out for you i will write the five
million dollar check for you to go do it
as far as a seed round uh
or up to five million if you want to let
other people in that's amazing this just
got spicy okay
oh my god what's the domain name that
you
[Music]
all right we just got done like 30
seconds ago talking to the guy who
we're gonna introduce you to now uh that
was amazing he's amazing that guy's
darmesh is amazing he's very cool um so
we have darmash i don't even know
what is starmesh's last name dharmasha i
think shaw i just know him as darmash um
he's the co-founder of he's like beyonce
you know they just go with the one name
at a certain point ron ronaldo beyonce
darmesh that's that's it
so darmesh um is the co-founder of
hubspot he's the largest shareholder i
mean we we got pretty uh
like into it right away we're like just
tell like it tell us what's it like to
be a billionaire
so i just googled your net worth and it
appears you're worth a billion dollars
yeah
so yeah how does that feel and he's like
uh
no i told him i was going to talk to him
about that so we talked to him about
just like well
let's rattle off some of the dope things
he's done so started hubspot hub spots
like
whatever 25 billion dollar company or
something like that but he's done some
other cool things early investor in
coinbase dropbox and loads of different
stuff
right and then also just has kind of
like he's like us he's got that itch
that entrepreneurial itch so
he like we talk a little bit about he's
got like 20 domain names some domain
names that are worth like you know
millions of dollars and others that are
you know just
simple ideas everybody has an idea by
the way hundreds of domain names
right but he's like got ideas loaded
into them like oh
here's what you might do with this idea
and then here's a good domain name for
it
and so i think he's you know he's sort
of like he's one of our people
in that sense like he's an idea person
he's a frameworks person so he shared
some frameworks he shared a bunch of
ideas two two really big ideas
one idea on air he goes sean if you want
to start this i'll fund you right now
for five million dollars
yeah he made me an offer i pretty much
couldn't refuse i just had to sort of
you know
uh yeah squeeze my thighs and sit still
here so so
you know but i thought it was exciting i
thought the actual ideas were really
great
um so i think people are gonna like that
we talked a little bit about the
we talked a little bit about wealth we
talked a little bit about kind of like
early days
you know hubspot and hustle acquisition
and then we talk a bunch about ideas
and then we uh some of those ideas are
about like a new different type of
linkedin or remote community
we talked about um oh he talked about
his framework for evaluating if
an idea is good or not if he should
pursue it that was actually
incredibly educational it was awesome
dude it was great so uh
we'll get to the episode can you guys do
me a favor though
click that subscribe button on itunes
and that follow button
on spotify that would mean a lot uh do
we have to tell them anything else
well there's a thing going around where
if you just post on your social networks
and you're just like hey
you know psa to whoever needs this this
podcast
you know makes my commutes amazing this
is the best business podcast
hands down um you know good karma comes
to you in your next life so that's just
something if you're interested in having
a good next life i would just do that
yeah and i'll reshare that for sure
i mean because it impacts my ego and we
hit i hit i share
all i share all compliments so go ahead
and do that make sure you share the
itunes or spotify link with it thank you
very much here's the thing about me i
like compliments all right yeah
all right enjoy this episode i don't
remember what i was going to say but
right before you came on i was asking
darmesh what he listens to and he says
that he listens to us
almost every day for the past 60 days
amazing has that uh changed you have you
probably become a worse person you seem
like a pretty good person i feel like if
you listen to us for
60 straight days there's gonna be a part
of your brain that's good but a part
that gets like corrupted slightly
you know it's i think that's true that's
an astute observation
um it's you know we've just have uh i
won't say like completely diverge in
past so i'm just
a yeah it's been good though i'm a
believer in
and like just these kind of orthogonal
things that's like oh this is not stuff
i'm like you know
looking at retail businesses or like you
guys have a wide array of stuff
um but i think that kind of thing like
builds a different muscle group and i
think it's been it's gonna be useful for
me um i'll put it to you that way it's i
think we're not
uh right at birth by any stretch we have
things that you know we reflectively
have in common but um
there are things that i'm just different
and it'll come out in the pods
i'm a weirdo we're on now so this is a
pod but we uh
yeah this might i have a feeling this
might go a little long and i'm okay with
that
uh sean do what you want but we um
i like in my world so i was just hanging
out with heaton shaw yesterday
and your name came up we were just
talking to nathan barry the other day
your name
came up sean and i are in this text
group where people talk about big clout
your name comes up
your name comes up everywhere like
you're you've got you're like a little
like you got like a spider web like you
get your hands and all these little
things and
i i think part of it's because you've
been in the game for a while and you're
incredibly successful
but do you so uh this is dar mesh
darmesh is the
uh you're the co-founder of hubspot is
your title cto
yes do you are you active like are you
working really hard at hubspot like how
do you have time to
have your hands on all this different
stuff uh so the answer is
yes uh hubspot is my obsession and
preoccupation uh anything else that you
see me doing
uh there's probably some diabolical
threat that connects it back to hubspot
there is right um so yeah it's my baby
it's the thing that
uh i spend pretty much all of my
kind of non-family time non-personal
time on um so it's my
and i just want to describe for people
who are not watching so you should go to
the youtube channel it's youtube.com
i think hustlecon and you'll see the
videos but uh
so here's what i see so darmesh is
sitting there he's got a keyboard like a
piano keyboard to his right
uh he's got i think a steve jobs uh
piece of art behind him or is that
lennon or something like that i can't
tell exactly who it is john lennon maybe
um and you're in this room so just is
this where you work on a day-to-day
basis uh so this is
well yes and no so that's why you're
getting tricks sean you're getting
tricked listen
this is my living room um but it's a
like i capture a moment in time when the
living room was somewhat
less disorganized than it usually would
be but it's a virtual background i've
got the green screen and things set up
so i can
oh okay that's pretty good because you
usually when you have a green screen
it's like half your head also turns into
like the background
and uh this one's actually pretty good
all right i'm impressed i've done like a
multiple green screen so i'm sort of
surrounded with it so if i need to twist
the camera one way or the other um
so you're kind of doing the oasis thing
we talked about you basically you have a
virtual background but the virtual
background is not just you on a beach
like a fake
situation it's your actual living room
when it's like clean and perfect the way
you want it or whatever
and you're like that's what i want my
background to be regardless of the
reality of the the current whatever your
current situation is
i like that trick really cool is that
the keyboard itself is actually real
that's not part of the background
you'll see
so let me um let me do like a a very
brief intro and like an overview of what
we're going to talk about so
darmash sent us like a list of ideas
we're going to get into them but i need
to give a background here
so the listeners entirely understand so
hubspot
today is like a 25 or 30. i don't know
whatever the market cap is
uh so 25 billion dollar publicly traded
company you co-founded it
15 years ago i think prior to that you
had another startup that you sold for a
significant amount of money we can talk
about that
throughout this whole time you own uh i
believe
millions and millions of dollars worth
of domains like you
um you bought your wife like as a a gift
humanism.com which we gotta talk about
that's pretty funny you've um
you're an eight or an angel investor in
a lot of different startups including
coinbase and things like that
you've got your hands on all these
different things like you
according to wallmind or
wallstreetmind.com
you're worth today 850 billion
million dollars uh so like
you you do a little bit of everything in
the world of business it's incredibly
fascinating and so
i wanted to today talk about you might
be
well you might be the wealthiest person
we've ever had on this podcast i'm going
to ask you questions about that
um i don't know it's fine please
we're going to we're going to ask you
questions it doesn't really matter
that's one thing i've learned we can
talk about that too well that's
that's okay if it doesn't matter we're
going to talk about it we're also going
to talk about
um your ideas uh we're going to talk
about
building hubspot we're talking about why
you invest in what you invest and we're
going to talk about
um uh do you ever invest in non-startup
stuff we're going to invest
about we're going to talk about a lot of
stuff sean what do you think
well i would have asked them okay so
here's my question my question is
actually not about
uh darmesh it's actually about uh sam so
uh so you
see i've always wondered this so you
acquired the hustle
and i hope you could be as uh as
transparent as you want here i think sam
will
will not care um so i would say
dna wise the hustle is kind of a unique
company sam's a pretty unique
uh dude that you kind of brought into
your company different dna probably than
the vast majority of employees there uh
give me kind of like
well and you do you're part of the deal
too sean so you're in the book
you don't have to deal with me on a
day-to-day basis so so
doing that deal and bringing these guys
in i guess like i don't know are there
any interesting observations
any entertaining little stories about
either pre-acquisition or post that had
to do with
you know sam and the hustle i'm just
curious kind of like what's your view on
that side of the table
because i've only been on the same side
that sam's on yeah and we haven't
hubspot has not done a lot of
acquisitions uh in the past we've done a
handful of them
uh pretty much most of them have gone
well the one thing that made this
different i think as you as you observed
is
um the dna of the hustle is different
than hubspot
and um and that's both a good thing and
a bad thing so the thing i was
worried about is um and and i
until now i don't think sam and i have
actually ever had a one-on-one chat so
this is my therapy session therapy
for uh two people johnny
the thing i was worried about is that um
you know so sam is a kind of what i
would think of as a kind of type a
personality um just
like he's out there he's hustling
against the uh name of the company um
which is fine but it's just not uh most
of the makeup of hubspot is not
that we're very we're uh i don't know
what the right it's gonna
overly stereotype us but we're not type
a we're like a kinder
gentler humble just quieter
kind of company um so that's one thing
oh here let me explain it this way
sam would be described as brash i don't
think anybody would ever describe pub
spot as brash
well today kieran the guy i work with
technically my boss he was like
you should probably hire someone outside
of hubspot for this role for your growth
and i was like well why he goes
i think you're too direct for anyone who
works at hubspot it's like that
that's an example i think that was good
advice but um but it's worked out it's
worked out well so there have been um
like the one kind of minor story i can
recall there was a
like a twitter back and forth that i
think sam had with uh rand fishkin i
don't know if you recall this sam that
there was something that was said about
vcs or investment or something
and ran's been a good friend it's like
an and uh but it's like oh okay well
it's fine i'm like okay you know it's
like
and not like either party was right
wrong or indifferent but i know them you
know
at least now a little bit uh both but
anyway so it's but it's been fine
in my defense i i hope and even our
podcast defense
our goal is we will disagree with people
but i hope that it never comes from a
place of like
disrespect or i'm trying to like hurt
your feelings
no but i will say i do put entertainment
first sometimes so sometimes i will poke
the bear for the entertainment value of
it when
you know the kinder nicer simpler thing
to do would be to do
to do nothing or just back away uh so i
do like to have fun
either on twitter or the podcast hubspot
too much but one thing i will say this
was as far as the deal itself
it was one of the better things hubspot
has done um
in terms of like the strategy behind it
i think um
is strong in terms of like it gets
hubspot into a thing which is where i
think the future of
kind of sas companies has is going to be
heading which is
more and more of them are going to
control their own kind of distribution
versus kind of renting
audiences from other people and recent
horses and there's other deals that have
been done around the same timeline but
i'm a believer in companies kind of
controlling their destiny in terms of
distribution versus constantly just
buying from
buying audiences and renting them from
someone else see this is where you
should just say
just drop a one line be like you know
and we got it at a fantastic price just
to drive sam
crazy for the next seven years just
leave him constantly questioning himself
look i think there yeah could we have
sold for more definitely maybe like that
always is a maybe right
um i think that when we sold hubspot i
felt was undervalued
uh i think when i think the day the deal
closed it was or
maybe like what was the stock in january
was it like it was worth like 350
or was it even less 250 i don't remember
today today it's 600 bucks so like our
guess
my guess was that i think hubspot is
undervalued um
and also i wanted to create a reputation
of someone who was like a fair deal
maker and like
like i think people will know that uh
like if i built something i sold it
the all all parties got a good deal
and so okay all right sounds good we can
switch off the hubs the hustle
acquisition so let's do some ideas
no wait i want to talk about one thing
really quick can we let's talk about
money stuff
okay because i told darmesh i was gonna
ask him this
so first of all is it weird that i know
what your net worth is today because
it's like public information
um it's not weird for me honestly like
i'm
a um i'm generally like transparent i
believe in kind of the openness
um of the web it's um and i'm a in a
sense it's a publicly traded company
like that's
you know what i want my bank accounts
and all my accounts kind of published on
the web no
but the fact that i'm an executive in a
publicly traded company and most of my
net worth
is in the form of shares which you can
take the number of shares which is on
the public record and multiply it by the
current price and get
which is probably roughly 85 90 of my
overall net worth because that's where
all my money
is in hubspot shares um i don't find
that weird uh it's
yeah has your life changed as this as
this has like
accumulated and and things got didn't
different or has it basically so you had
another company before this how much did
you sell that for uh
10 or 15 in that range based on how you
count it and
has your life changed since that moment
significantly because that's a that's a
significant number in itself right
yeah so here here's the thing it's um
and i'd like to say no
you know i wasn't focused on money or
i'm not focused on at the time when i
was younger
i was very very focused on money and i
had very kind of modest upbringing and i
was like okay well
it wasn't like the money and the
accumulation of it it was the freedom
you know ever since i was little i i
always want to kind of configure the
universe to my liking
so to speak because i've got my quirks
so like these are things the way i like
to do things um
and having to kind of work in a normal
kind of classic job doesn't give you a
whole lot of control over your
your part of the universe you don't get
to control who you work with all that
much or who you hire you don't have
a lot of degrees of freedom um so
yeah i've been thinking back and then i
you know i kind of thought about money
um and like the first i'll say five
million or so
um has a dramatic impact had a dramatic
impact on my life right because that
buys you
an inordinate amount of freedom right
you don't have to work again um
you can invest in things you can do
pretty as long as you're not out you
know buying small islands and overtaking
countries
i mean that's a decent amount of money
for for folks right um and then
after that and their other kind of i
don't know exactly what the
demarcations are where you know more
money adds
on a marginal basis a little bit more
freedom you can do more things um but
you know like the kinds of things i do
like i enjoy food and restaurants
there's only so much you can actually
spend as a reasonable human being even
if you like
the finer things it's like okay unless
you're trying to make a statement and
spend
100 times with the average of whatever x
is it's kind of hard to
you know specifically well even if you
have kind of
high-end taste honestly the most common
thing i've heard
i don't know if you would agree or
disagree is like there's these levels so
it's like first
uh in depth in if when you're in debt to
no debt that's like the first jump where
oh freedom
got this weight off my shoulders yeah
then there's kind of like you know
um uh it's what i'll call there's a zero
to one million where it's like oh my god
you know
mentally i'm a millionaire that's kind
of just like a mentally freeing concept
an interesting concept that's why we
named the pod what we did
but also you know that that'll afford
you a certain type of lifestyle
and then the next jump i've heard is
like at 10 or 10 or
10ish where it's sort of like okay at
tennis you sort of um
you don't have to work like at a million
you still got to work at 10 you don't
have to work
you can kind of like have a couple
places to live you could do whatever you
want you don't really need to
check the prices when you go do things
and then there's sort of like
100 or more which is sort of like you
know the uh
ego gets involved it's like okay now i'm
keeping score against you know in the in
the business olympics against
against these other folks and also you
know i could do some like
you know like i can i can i can buy an
island i can buy a piece of an nba team
i can
i can go do these different things that
are like kind of like bucket list
and and the joy what i've heard is sort
of like you know for most people is sort
of like the joy actually like
de-escalates from the from the beginning
there like
getting out of debt is sort of like the
most relief most joy
and then sort of like it starts to
diminish sort of step by step as you go
like
the 10 to 100 feels a lot less impactful
and less
sort of changes your joy in your mood
than uh like going from zero to ten
yeah i just have two friends i want to
pull on as long as we're talking about
money
um so one is one thing that's kind of
helped me reconcile it
um in terms of um you know having to be
in the net worth now is
you know the plan my wife and i have
talked about this the plan is to donate
90 plus percent of it right like we have
one child we're not going to spoil him
so it's not like we're trying to build a
multi-generational dynasty that is right
not the goal
um and so then like you know if i
make a really good return on a startup
or something like that it's like okay
well i'm
discount 90 for my wife's foundation
that's essentially what it comes down to
right
right it moves 90 of whatever it is uh i
mean i don't i think it'll end up being
higher because i just don't think we're
capable of actually spending the
spending the money um but yeah so that
makes me feel better but just kind of
taking it back to the early days one
kind of
lesson i learned early early on and this
is useful um
beginning part of my career is the kind
of the relationship between time and
money
and one thing is that we spend the
better part of the first half of our
lives converting
time into money right and you're looking
for the hours you're looking for yeah
you want to get that you know rate up as
you can and then the latter half of
you're desperately trying to buy time
back
with the money however best you can
right so that's um and it varies a
little bit as to
when that kind of turn happens but the
thing that i kind of learned this was
and
i thought about it probably a few years
after that um so i was making
3.65 cents uh in my first job when i
came over
as an immigrant and i worked all the way
through school took me
seven degrees to get my seven years to
get my four-year degree i was working
full-time the whole way through
um and that wasn't a lot of money and as
it turns out
um i had to do pretty much nothing was
delegatable but then once i got to the
point where i was making 10 20 50
an hour it's like okay well now and like
all of my time i can make as much
billable as i want to as
much as i'm humanly possible willing to
work there was someone willing to pay me
for that time i was an engineer
that's how things work back then it was
and the the pivotal point for me is i i
got this uh
it was in my early 20s i got this bump
to like 125
hours working as an engineer and that
was an ungodly amount of money i was in
birmingham alabama this is the uh the
90s uh that was like real money right
and i was working lots i was
making a fair amount so then i made the
decision that if there's anything i'm
doing with my time
that could be done by spending less than
125 an hour i'm being an idiot by
actually doing it
right if i enjoy it that's a different
story but if i'm not it's just stupid
and so i've carried that kind of idea
it's like okay so what value would i
place in my time
right what is occupying my time that i
can kind of delegate or even if i'm
paying a premium it's like okay
i could pay 75 an hour just up for
someone to pay you know to mow my lawn
yeah i hate it but it's still profitable
right like you're
like why would you do that like i would
do that every day of the week um so the
one thing that's changed for me
um so now like i went back and did the
math because i knew i was going to be on
this podcast and you might be folks like
numbers if i
let's say i've worked on average 60
hours a week and i've done that for
about 30 years give or take um
it's my kind of professional career my
average hourly rate across the 30 years
would be like 10 000
an hour right and now it's back loaded
right
effectively by hourly rate and so now
it's like okay well if there's anything
and i would actually pay a premium right
now right above that right like so
i would not spend my time even an hour
on anything
that wasn't worth at least to that it's
like okay well like the future of me
would buy for 50 100 000
if there's some option value on that
time anyway the the short message
is uh most people don't value their time
enough
and don't think about it objectively
enough and it like anything else is a
resource but it's finite um but put a
number on it
and then ask yourself like what are the
things i'm doing with my time that are
not worth that
um right and so naval has this uh
phrase in his like kind of how to get
rich uh podcast or whatever how to get
rich without getting lucky
he says um he goes you know put up put
it
up put a um i don't know what he calls
it like an outrageously uh outrageous
hourly rate for yourself
like an emba a super ambitious rate
ambitious one one that's way beyond
wherever you're at he's like you know
ever since i was young this is like one
of the smart things i did i just said
five thousand dollars an hour some like
really aspirational hourly rate
he's like if my friends used to laugh
and joke like dude you bought this
blender you're not even using it go
return it and he's like no i'm not gonna
go return it i don't i don't enjoy it
and it's gonna get me back 30 for the
hour round trip you know going and
returning this thing at target
so like i will throw it away i'll give
it away what i will not do is i will not
give my time back into that because the
hourly rate just doesn't make
sense i love that so
i've done a similar thing and it's kind
of funny to like pick that hourly mark
um because it sounds crazy like i my mom
will get mad at me she'll come to my
house and she'll see the way i'm living
and she's like
oh my god like this this bill is late
they're gonna there's a 75
fee if you don't do it and i'm like i'm
not calling them
and they can charge me the 75 fee they
could charge it to me 10 times like i'm
not gonna use this hour like
and i'll tell her like look literally my
hourly rate is x
right it's like thousands of dollars so
so are you that's my hourly rate so i'm
not going to trade that hour to go do
this thing i don't enjoy
um because her other argument is well
you go watch tv and i'm like well that i
enjoy so that that i'm actually spending
the money
um but sam i know you're a little bit
different like when i went to go visit
sam in austin he had like cvs receipts
that he had been saving
in his like glove compartment of his
super fancy car uh like he's a dichotomy
right he's got he's got well
he likes to spend some things but he's
also enjoys being frugal it's like that
makes me
yeah that makes me feel good about
myself right like i guess the question i
have for you is do you also have an
hourly rate
do you think about that or you don't do
that that framework sam is for you
oh for me um yeah i have that framework
yeah so like uh
yeah i mean it makes me feel good not to
waste stuff like i feel good about
myself and i feel guilty if i waste it
so i feel
i feel happy when i do that and i feel
it's hard for me to go to bed at night
if i
if i waste something or i don't return
it um yeah i have that hour i mean i
mean i have that rate like i just assume
that i'm gonna make
um i i assume that i'm gonna make three
million dollars a year so whatever that
hourly rate is but i i think i'm gonna
make three million dollars a year
and um anything that like will make less
than that i
don't want to do it but that said like
mowing the lawn
i get joy from that so i have no problem
i don't like put a money
thing on anything but like if someone's
like hey will you uh
in fact sean someone asked us to fly to
london to come speak at some event or
something
and i um i'll afford it to you but
they're like yeah it's october and i'm
like i don't want to go there i'm like
how much money would they have to pay me
to go and do this i'm like they have to
pay me a lot like right because you'll
say
yeah yeah excited i just don't they just
that just as a payment they'd have to
pay me a hundred thousand dollars to do
that and like that does not make any
sense
but i just hate i just hate it and uh so
darmesh a couple more uh rich guy
questions and we like these because
honestly um you never get to ask these
even if we were just hanging out
personally i could never ask you this
but for the for some reason with the
podcast it's like sort of okay for me to
just like ask you random
questions like this and i told him when
he wanted to come on or
i asked him to come on i go i'm going to
ask you this stuff and we gave him an
easy out i said if you don't want to
answer anything just say you don't want
to answer it
right and i'm sort of projecting here
where um
you know i guess like i think i put
myself in your shoes what if i had
more money that i could ever spend what
would i do and so my question to you is
um what whether you did it or did or you
just considered it
what's a sort of outlandish use of funds
that you've either considered or done
like so for example
you know some people are like yeah you
know like some people like jets that's
not
i'm not buying a private jet i'm but
what i really care about is i love this
sock so i bought
every i love jordan's sneakers so i
bought every pair of jordans
i have this closet in my house just full
of these things because i always wanted
it when i was a kid right or
if they overspend in some area and they
they're just happy to have done it
or like um it could be like
philanthropic like i think if i had a
billion dollars
i think like two days a year i would
just wire somebody like a million
dollars
i would literally just wire a random
person a million dollars and i would
just see how that plays out and i think
it would bring me like tons of joy and
entertainment
to do that and see how they react and
what happens and what do they what do
they do with it like maybe some kid
who's working on something interesting i
would just be like look
here check your account it's there uh
you know
so give me something that is there
anything that's sort of non-standard
that you either have done or considered
doing
yeah the thing that i do is i like those
kind of
um kind of micro acts of kind of
spontaneity that says oh
like someone is wants to go to this
event or something like that and can't
afford it or whatever it's like i'll be
a sponsor like
if you can find people that want to do
this go do this um i'll
do that relatively regularly i've taken
this the sound
so i've taken my average tip amount up
to between 50 and 100 percent um
everywhere i go
and this is partly because i want to
make up for all the time when i was
younger that
probably did not dip well so i'm trying
to average it out and that's
as long as i can do it without like
drawing too much attention because i
don't want to be that weirdo guy it's
like okay knows like right
send some time the wrong signals i want
to do it um i do that by the way modesty
um
it's okay it's just i typically tip 50
it makes me feel good
yeah um it's it's yeah and i've worked
in the service industry before i know
that
those kinds of things matter um so i'm a
cheap bastard so i'll stay silent here
in terms of like you know large things
so
flying through me the running joke
inside the house is uh my wife and i and
so she's not from the tech world at all
but um so i'm really
so i want to like own the world and she
wants to save it right like
so i will make the money yeah that's
something i've uh been relatively good
at
and she will be able to channel it to
good causes and the film for epic effort
so she'll be able to do that
um so i don't have any like particular
specific things um i will say like i am
a
so i'm the guy that's like jacked with a
matrix so if there was a world it's like
oh it's like this is
um you know like i live a virtual world
so there's no not a lot of physical
things
uh that i crave or desire other than a
piano which i've wanted for a while and
i have now a piano
but it doesn't excite me all that much
right it's like it's
and because atoms there's a maintenance
to atoms right like atoms versus bits
like if you have
whether it's a yacht or whatever it is a
plane like that takes
calories i could take i don't care how
much you've delegated whatever that's
something in your life that's kind of
attached to you somehow and i just don't
like that i don't like that idea
it feels more weighty to me than uh kind
of joyful
but yes so speaking of time we um
so hubspot 15 years old i don't know how
many people are here
2 500 3 000 whatever um it seems like
you guys like grew
pretty fast early on but has it always
felt like a grind or i mean like when i
when i see you i'm like well you don't
have to do this
um like you could delegate this you
don't have to work here you're set
you're good
why are you still doing this and does it
still feel like a grind and when has it
stopped feeling like a grain one of the
reasons why i wanted to sell to you
um i was like if i don't sell like in
this cycle i'll probably have to wait
another five years
am i do i want to put that work in or do
i want to sell now like what like that's
a hard challenge
did you face that and just walk me
through that yeah
so a couple things um it's not widely
known but um
so brian is co-founders we had a kind of
heart-to-heart co-founder chat which i
encourage all founders to have and we
have this list of questions we're going
to go through
and i've published this on my uh on my
own startups blog
but one of the things was around um
who's going to be ceo and we decided
he's gonna be ceo
because i suck at being ceo i you know i
did that with my first startup for 10
years
i'm just not that good at it so that was
kind of decision one but decision two
which is much
um much more unconventional
is that i have no direct reports so what
my agreement with brian was i'm not
going to have any management
responsibilities in this company i'm
going to be in it 100
but i'm not a good manager now i'm
reasonably smart guy if i spent a bunch
of time i could probably with some
coaching
get passively okay at management like i
think i could get there
i don't want to spend 10 20 30 years of
my life getting passively good at
something i'm a big believer in
take your strengths whatever they are
and put like
all your energy into kind of amplifying
those strengths and getting really
really good
at that thing and don't worry about your
weaknesses all that much so i don't want
to worry about my weakness managing
people
and so we have over 4 000 people at
hubspot i have zero direct reports i've
never had direct reports in the 15 years
and that is partly what makes it much i
don't think of it as a grind
at all like it's completely
discretionary and optional for me uh
obviously i have a lot of
kind of vested interest in the company
but in terms of the work that i do and
i've
sort of whittled down my life at a
hubspot um this has been
the this way for better part of a decade
um
is is like i get it down to like three
things i'm gonna work on and that i will
change those every few years
um so for a long time it was like brand
uh culture and what i call boldness
which is
is the organization taking on enough
risk because the temptation is always
like once you start
having customers and the revenues are
growing things like that is just the
kind of
what we call drag the spreadsheets like
oh like here's the numbers this is how
it's growing we're just going to drag
the spreadsheet
and the numbers will flow basically um
is to push the organization so we don't
do that
um so what i do is i will maniacally
focus on whatever those three things are
and say no to pretty much everything
else and and things will swap in and out
so i've had
you know product in there i've had
platform in there um
but on that thing whatever it is i'm
working on so when i had culture on my
list
it's like i spent 300 hours you know in
the on the culture code deck at hubspot
like
i'm going to uh do everything i can to
learn everything i can to try and get
culture to be a thing an upspot um
and yeah so it's i find it enjoyable i
get to kind of pick the things so my
three things
are different um you know from year to
year i like to dig into the details i
don't like kind of
floating at 50 000 feet in lofty ivory
towers i like to like if i'm going to
work on brand
i'm in there with the marketing team
like reviewing copy and
uh going through the and this is why i'm
taking sean's uh copywriting or like i
i obsess over details um so anyway yep
did you see sean that he's in your power
writing course yeah i saw that i was
like how does this guy have time to do
this this is amazing
well have you how's it been so far he
talks to me all the time that's why i'm
like what do you do all day
um i i found it very useful i'll say
that it's
uh and i think copywriting overall
is one of the most underrated skills uh
in
entrepreneurship generally like if
people do not realize the amount of
leverage you get by just spending 10 20
50 hours
and you can learn a lot of what you need
just by like reading the top three books
on it and just
practicing the craft right it's a doable
thing
and the nice thing about it and one
thing i love about it it's like
measurable you can objectively measure
whether you got better at copywriting or
not you can look at your conversion
rates to whatever numbers you're trying
to
to move as a result of your words uh and
it's a it's a learnable skill
um that's yeah one more question and we
can move on but
when and the reason why you were able to
do those no direct reports is i think
that you were the first
investor and so like was this was
hubspot your idea or was it brian's idea
but i think you invested
like half a million dollars of your own
money to like get it started and
aren't aren't you the largest
shareholder of the company
i am um and so so the idea of hubspot is
that you have to decouple the two things
um so hubspot was not supposed to happen
and here's what i mean by that when i
sold my last company
and i had been running it for 10 hours
uh 10 years and working the proverbial
entrepreneurial hours as one would
expect right it was self-funded uh
bootstrapped and i promised my wife
um that i would not do another startup
it's like okay well
you know the one i'm doing i'm in i
can't not be in uh the analogy um
you know i use this it's a little bit
like being at um
like a a gaming table in las vegas right
and it's like and you don't know the
rules of the game this is how startup
entrepreneurship works up here if you're
self-funded
it's like you're at the table and the
only real feedback you get is like
sometimes the chips go down sometimes if
they go up
you're playing you're trying to figure
out the rules as you go you don't know
but there's one like cardinal rule is
that if you leave the table
whatever chips you have on the table
they're gone every now and then the
house will come up to you and say hey
would you like to cash into your chips
they're worth x dollars and this is the
position you were in so i was like okay
would you like to sell your company
here's what someone's willing to pay for
it
and if you miss that opportunity you
have no idea when the next opportunity
to cash out your chips and
again so you keep playing right it's
like and so the thing i told my wife is
like
i have to keep playing i did like if i
chose to get off the table it's like
yeah a lot of lessons this
100 of our net worth was invested in
this um
and so then eventually when i sold um
that was a decision it's like okay i'm
i'm leaving the table cashing in my
chips
i don't have to do this anymore so
that's why i went to grad school and my
plan was go to grad school
um i didn't really get a chance to uh
enjoy undergrad because i was working
the whole time through and i'm gonna
actually go to grad school be a real
student apply myself and not go do
anything
how old are you i was 35 36
somewhere in that range um yep so
like a 36 year old college kid living
the dream i had a great time it was
awesome
one of the best things i did um is go
back to grad school for a variety of
reasons
but anyway so i had not planned enough
so my plan was go to grad school
then maybe get like a phd and then go
teach that was my kind of
path uh my kind of chosen path uh and
then i met brian in grad school
and we both have this kind of shared
passion for smb we both come from tech
different backgrounds
and so the first decision we made uh
before we even decided what hubspot was
going to be was that the two of us
should do a company together
and if like brian was not going to do a
company there would be no hubspot right
like i so i had registered the domain
name i had kind of noodled on kind of
variety of things but then we kind of
came together and said
let's do this and by the way all through
grad school um
we were dueling on ideas right we're
like okay well we'll do this and we had
house five we went to the business plan
competition wrote a business plan for
early versions of upspot
which is fun to look at um but the idea
came after
like we had kind of narrowed it down to
two companies um two
past one was in marketing which is what
we ended up doing the other one was like
a
oracle for small business like an erp
similar to netsuite which you folks were
talking about in the last episode
uh all right so let's do some ideas
because i think you know one of the cool
things
what i love about any technically minded
person
who has business success is typically
when
when people who are non-technical get
into business they go in one of two
paths they
um they sort of become a financier
they're like great still love business
but i don't want to sweat anymore so
i'll invest
and uh and lots of people invest but
they make investing the main thing
and um what i found is that a lot of
people who are technical that end up
being successful
um they never stop loving kind of what's
new where technology is going
how behaviors are changing that sort of
thing and whether they start a new
company or not
um they sort of live as a user at the
edge and so
um so tell me like i guess what's what
maybe one or two kind of technologies or
ideas right now spaces that are
most exciting to you at the moment
uh two one is around kind of broadly
defined cryptocurrency
um and we haven't talked about big cloud
yet but i'll bring that out
is a cryptocurrencies as applied to
other kind of mainstream things so the
i if i we're not doing hubspot which i
have no plans of doing anything else
but um this is the idea of i'm gonna i'm
gonna give you my pitch sean
yeah what you should do since now you're
out of twitch um you should do
a professional network um that's powered
by the blockchain
that i'm going to say this is kindly
that
uh people love uh because the people
don't love the incumbent right now
can i can i say my opinion you know you
know my opinion can you cool if i say it
yeah yeah good
linkedin sucks how about this
a lot of people say linkedin sucks and
um
you're suggesting bill that building a
different one um
i even have a seven figure domain name
picked out for you i will write the five
million dollar check for you to go do it
as far as a seed round uh or up to five
million if you want to let other people
in that's amazing
this just got spicy okay oh my god
what's the domain name that you have
i am i am dead serious i have uh and you
yeah um
so and here here's why it needs to wait
let's play this out yeah keep going
so the issue right now is that you know
linkedin
yes people don't like it it was a
product that was great for its time
uh and times have changed now there's a
different kind of need
and the thing i'm excited about is the
intersection of a couple of things one
is um you know we didn't have
things like big cloud or cryptocurrency
before now we do
right one of the issues with linkedin is
like okay well you've got the kind of
spam issue you've got all this like okay
well how do i separate all the noise
from the signal that's just
it's just a pain in the ass over time
right the acne tonic move for
linkedin is like diminishing utility
right it's like it's just going to
become painful and
then there's there's a cap on where you
can go with it so imagine
uh that you and so big cloud ended up
doing twitter with the blockchain
imagine if there was something else that
did linkedin on the blockchain and you
have your own kind of currency and then
you could say hey you know what
i'm afraid i'm an engineer that's a free
agent or whatever and for
500 i will look at your company and
apply for it i'll do a reasonably good
job or for
ten dollars i'll open your email or for
x i'll do this
it's like okay there's a right now
there's an inherent uh so the thing the
cool thing about big cloud is
everybody's got a price
right everybody's got every coin has a
certain value and so the beauty of
uh of a professional one would be right
now when you go on linkedin
um it is not obvious the level of
hierarchy right and so you always have
people who are
uh either recruiters or people who are
at the bottom of the career ladder
trying to keep connecting and reaching
out to the people at the top of the
career ladder and they have no real
incentive to
to to do it so they just sort of ignore
linkedin all together
why would i even go to this site i'm
just going to get inundated with crap
that i don't really want and so the
beauty of this is that
because everybody has a coin value you
sort of inherently have baked in
this sort of like career worth career
value that this person is bringing to
the table into the network and so you
know
um hey somebody has a way to buy
attention so they buy your coin which
increases your price so it's a mutual
beneficialness right now
if i go pay linkedin i can send you spam
inmail
you do not receive any of the revenue
from me paying linkedin for the right to
spam you
right in this case i could say hey if
you want to spam me if you want me to
read your thing and you want me to
to respond to it here's my prices so it
becomes revenue generating for me
the second thing is that when somebody
reaches out i can quickly assess
their value in the network based on how
how much other people believe in this
person how much other people weight
this person and so now it's not this
kind of like every node kind of looks
the same on the surface no they would
not look the same on the surface which
is really cool
correct and just one more thing yeah so
yes so that there's a kind of crypto
angle where everyone's got a price the
other angle
is uh is we'll call it page rank
for the professional graph right so
right now the professional that's cool
it's all uh it's all symmetric right so
every person you follow
gets an equal number of follow value
whatever their account goes up by
exactly one
it's not weighted in any single uh any
anyway
explain page rank a little bit so the
kind of the beauty behind google the
original idea that made it
um the powerhouse is today is they said
okay well how do we
determine what the best set of results
are to show for a keyword search right
and
it came down to two things one is like
the overall context of the page so if
you're searching for
uh real estate boston or something like
that it'll look at all the pages that's
indexed it's like okay well this
these set of pages are about real estate
in boston to varying degrees that's kind
of
factor one in the function so which
people also just
say good content yeah exactly we'll just
call it quality like the context
content yeah which is a whole round
whole thing authority right and the
authority is the where page rank comes
in though they say okay here's this
individual web page that's sitting on
the internet
we're going to measure its authority by
how many links are coming into that page
because that's a
that's this endorsement of effect and
the value of those links passed to that
individual page the page rank value of
it
the authority that gets passed through
is based on the page rank of those pages
right so it's a recursive function to
say oh
well if the new york times links to you
that's much more valuable than if
dharmesh's blog links to you because new
york times has more pagerank
last piece of the pagerank thing which
is super important to know is that the
amount of page rank you pass
across the links from your page are
proportional to your page rank so let's
say i have two units of page rank i'm
making the number up
and if i link to just one person it's
your blog sam
all the page rank i have on that page
accrues to you by transference if i link
to 10 different people it gets
distributed across those ten links
yeah it's a weighted graph versus just a
symmetrical graph where
we're not so now if you imagine a
professional network graph
where everything was graphed was like
okay well you know i endorse sam and i
have a certain authority i have a
certain currency if we've got a
cryptocurrency underneath it
as a result of which sam's currency goes
up
by x amount so it's not just me buying
shares it's just by that
so i think the the notion of a follow
should go away it's like if you really
really like that person
buy a dollar buy five dollars or
something like that right like that's
the one kind of
so so what you're saying is just to make
sure i understand so what you were
saying is
instead of just following sam which you
have an infinite supply and
um you know sort of this is a pretty
light signal you're saying
in this case you would be able to own
some of sam's coin that'd be a pretty
strong endorsement
and secondly the fact that your coin is
worth a lot
would mean that because you a valuable
person owns
sam's coin sam's coin goes up not just
by the five dollars you paid but buy
some multiple of that in terms of the
overall
algorithm the way the algorithm weights
sam's value now correct
so for instance if you raise money if
you're a startup and you raise money
from uh and recent or sequoia
like a million dollars is nine million
dollars yeah exactly
has an impact the same thing like you
know follow shouldn't matter the fact
that
you know that you follow me should
matter more than someone that doesn't
hasn't
that just joined twitter or big cloud or
whatever yesterday right like that's the
doesn't make it this is a tremendous
idea i'm having trouble containing
myself at the moment this is
this is one of the more exciting ideas
because people don't know exactly what i
came here for is to put you on the spot
uh he was like okay listen to this idea
that's insane you know because i got
excited about big clout
and i got excited about it because i
think that we do want a
social network that's inverted so
instead of one platform controlled by
one company that owns all the data
it's inverted it's inside out it's
basically no company
uh all the data is free and you own you
own your own business on top of it
and so i think that you know i don't
want to say how do i say decentralized
without saying decentralized that's my
way of saying it okay
so i think that's exciting and then a
whole bunch of people were like i can't
believe you're endorsing the scam
project and blah blah blah blah
is this is this going to make me rich or
is this not going to make me rich i'm
sort of like well it's besides the point
it might but uh it's besides the point
um it's more like this is what the the
next
twitter linkedin facebooks are gonna
look like um
in either one or ten years i'm not sure
and if big cloud or the next thing i'm
not sure but i'm gonna play with this
one and i'm gonna like
give it a ride so that when the right
one does arrive whether it's this one or
the next one
i've i've no i know what i'm looking at
i know what's real and what's not and
that's why i recommended people go
play with it just to see um just just be
on the forefront of it
something like it needs to exist right
whether it'll be the one or not i don't
know and so i've been
spending a fair amount of calories
trying to kind of understand the
mechanics of big cloud itself um money
did you do
on the uh top creators uh list so i've
been kind of moving up the
up the curve so to speak yeah dude the
thing about how much have you put into
big clout
uh it's gotta be a million dollars yeah
i mean the thing that pissed me off
about big clout
was i got into this like i had i didn't
get into it because i had to
i knew i was gonna get into this thing
i'm about to say but i i was getting too
i want to get into a pissing match real
fast
about building clout and because there
was money on the line and
yeah i just like oh i don't actually
want to get in this race
um i don't want to play that game and
that so that i i kind of had a little
like i one part of me is i actually
fundamentally agree with most everything
you're saying on the other part i'm like
oh
if this exists i'm going to be getting
in a lot of like pissing matches or
whatever and i'm going to be playing
more games and that kind of freaks me
out a little bit
yeah and this is one of the issues with
big clout right now right you have a
bunch of
like founder rewards games and things
like that and this is this is what
happens this is why we can't have nice
things
partly right like anytime something new
comes along there will be people that
are trying to game the system whatever
so even
back in the early days of google's like
the internet wasn't a scam and google
wasn't a scam but there were a bunch of
people trying to scan google to kind of
show up in the results and doing
kind of spammy seo kind of stuff you see
the same thing on big cloud right you
have to sort of
kind of separate that from the platform
it's like okay fundamentally the idea
does not feel like a scam to me
yes they needed to open it up and have
it listed on exchange so you can
actually take money out you know minor
details but um
it but they're fixing those i talked to
the
uh to the founder like in like one of
the few calls i've had in the last 12
months because i don't do phone calls um
but it feels legit to me and that's not
to say it's going to succeed
but it's i'm relatively confident it's
not a scam
that like this reason for being is not a
scam so one of the things that happens
with like a google or facebook is
you know like you said there's a big
honey pot either of users or money on
the line and so then you get
good people excited about it you got
technologies out of it but you also get
these sort of scammers and not even
scammers but i'll call them schemers
people who are not doing anything
illegal but they're thinking oh this is
a game how do i play it so that i get
the highest score and the score is
either money or followers or whatever
they're trying to game
yeah and uh whether this is like you
know buzzfeed and upworthy saying oh
newsfeed how do i game news feed to get
all this monthly traffic or
you know um zynga doing this with games
on facebook or whatever
with a company you sort of have the like
you know
for as much as people hate that facebook
and google can sort of censor and pull
the rug out from under you
they are able to like swat down these
schemers and scammers so that
um you know they don't ruin the
experience for everybody and
one thing that's interesting with
decentralized platforms is that
there's nobody in there's no ceo there's
nobody in charge to to do that
and so i think it's gonna be very
interesting how that plays out do you
have a sense of if that's going to be a
problem or do you think that there's a
solution to that with the
the governance i'm a believer in kind of
self-governance over time
like and it all depends on the time
horizon will it fix itself in a year or
two years
maybe not i think there's still going to
be this kind of dark parts of
big cloud that people don't want to
tread into but over time i think um
once bitcoin kind of figures out what it
wants to be when it grows up
um like what's the actual right now you
know the way i think of it is like the
kind of twitter use case is just a way
to kind of prove out the protocol
it just so happens they picked that one
they could have picked any number of
other ones um
but as people kind of build real things
using that underlying kind of technology
because it's
um an open protocol i think things will
settle down people will find a way that
they can implement use cases that
concretely solve a particular problem
and
stay away from some of the kind of dark
issues right now which is yeah
um what's the name that you bought for
for
sean you said you bought a seven-figure
domain name for this idea i have one in
i'm in the midst of negotiating the
price on it i'm not gonna reveal it uh
i don't wanna be outbid how many how
many letters is it
seven hmm okay i'll be very curious to
hear
this going to be you you had said two
spaces so the one one is the crypto
crypto social network yeah what was the
other space you're excited about
the other one um is some broadly defined
uh natural language
processing uh in terms of okay so let me
i'll do a
try to keep this a quick rant so every
software company that ever was
has always said our product is intuitive
and easy to use like okay well
and the reality is every one of them
lies because here's what happens in
order for a human to use software it's
like here's the thing i want to do
and i have some amount of training and
things whatever and i'm going to
translate the thing my intent
i'm going to translate into a series of
drags and clicks and swipes and touches
to make the software do the thing that i
intended to do right
now imagine uh if you know if i were eli
i'd be like okay well you should be able
to think the thought but let's put that
aside for now
let's just say you were like you're in
photoshop it's like i want to remove the
background
you should just be able to say well i
will remove the background if you're in
hubspot you should i want you to it's
like
you know how many new people signed up
for our service hub product
in the last 90 days you should just be
able to type that question in
because that's your intent not like oh
go to hubspot reporting tool build this
dashboard pull in here the three columns
you want or whatever and get to the
thing you want you should just be able
to say the thing you want express the
thing you want a better way to state it
and the software should figure it out
like we have the technology now on the
language side to be able to understand
natural language in
english and other languages and all we
really need is a translation layer and
so this is a
broad based in my mind um a mega trend
to be which is
in my mind bigger than mobile so mobile
was a oh we're good
the thing that mobile added for us which
is like oh well the thing that you used
to do on your desktop now you can do it
from anywhere and
enabled a bunch of different use cases
this thing is like okay well the thing
that
now you've been trying to learn you're
trying to use the software whatever that
you never really got good at you never
had the time now like
a billion people can use that piece of
software that wasn't even possible
before because they don't have to learn
the clicks and drags and things
they can express something they want and
the software can do it and then what i
would do if i were an enterprising vc is
like okay look so pick the categories
where this thing will have the biggest
impact
uh like you know business intelligence
reporting kind of stuff b2b software is
a natural fit
uh but i think can go elsewhere yeah and
uh we've seen the beginnings of this on
the consumer side with
things like alexa but like the b2b world
i think is open for
just make the software actually
intuitive they could do what i want
have you seen anyone besides i was gonna
say besides alexa have you seen any
hints of
what i call a magic trick it's when you
see somebody build a piece of software
and then they're like
yeah so you just do xyz and boom it's
done and you're like
holy [__] you got that you know you just
wove your magic wand and got that and
it's like
when you see a magic trick you it's very
hard to unsee and you kind of
can't look at the old software the same
way anymore it's like
instagram filters or something like that
it's like oh wait your photo looks like
that
oh [__] okay well now all my photos in
my camera look like [__]
in comparison like i can't even look at
these anymore um so have you seen any
cool magic tricks with conversational
uh or natural language classes closely
i've gotten so i
built something myself called growthbot
uh a few years ago
uh i remember that i remember growing up
type and it was for
it was built for marketers to be able to
get marketing data out both of your kind
of marketing systems something like a
hubspot or a mailchimp
but also just other data sources like oh
what are the top three keywords that
uber buys on ppc
like that data's out there right like we
already know to kind of ask that and so
uh or like when was this domain
registered or like just a bunch of
and i would go through every night and
look at all the questions people asked
of these things there was a blank canvas
they had no idea
what the thing was capable of and then i
would go back and it's like okay well
here are the repeating patterns wouldn't
it be nice if i could go update the
software to kind of do that thing so
that's
it came close it was i think a little
early i think we're further along now
people are more used to that notion
right um of being able to express
equipment that's so funny that you do
these i'm looking at the girl i
i remember growth bot uh like people
were sharing it
and i just you just made this did you so
you just
whipped up this landing page and you
made this i made the whole thing yeah
like i spent
a bunch of like time just learning about
what's possible coded the whole thing
myself
um god that's so funny can you um
gosh this is so funny uh you see that
sean yeah yeah i'm on it
it's great right like it's just cool
that you do this stuff
and you have uh within like everything
you do is
kind of related to hubspot right it's
all in the same world you also like
you're you're it seems like you're
really into website graders
is that right that business or what so i
was talking to a heaton shod the other
day he
shot um um he did everything
he's starting up near yeah nera he's got
uh which crazy egg crazy egg
uh quick sprout all types of [__] i mean
he's like you you just
[__] has his hands and everything but
he uh and his partner neil
have neil patel.com uber suggests and
then they also had neilpatel.com
like rate your website or something like
that why are you so into these website
rating businesses and products what what
the hell is going on with that well i'm
into
so the original thing was called website
grader it's actually a funny story so
back when we first started hubspot uh it
was just brian my co-founder and i and
we would go look at
people's websites and to see if they
would be a good fit for hubspot to
software or not right and so we would go
and
i would look at their age like i'd do a
view source in chrome and then look at
their source codes like okay do these
they do they have the right meta tags or
do they seem clueful right there's a
bunch of signals you can look and look
alexa ranking
stuff that you do you folks do all day
long right now
when you research companies like like a
similar web type of thing
yeah yeah and this is you know 15 years
ago and so we
so it's like okay well when we were all
doing it we were doing it manually there
were no tools it's like okay so i built
something
that's what i do it's like oh i'm going
to write this tool that does the
automatically those looks and
brings the apis we'll bring down the
source code for the html and see if
they're the tags are
right and kind of give it a for us give
it a score
and then i had this and had not planned
it this way was you know
built as a tool for just the two of us
um and it's like oh i'm going to put
this on the web
because i think this is useful and so
like okay well what
name can i give it well at grades
website i'm going to call it
websitegrader.com the domain was
available
15 years ago um and so i put that out
there and
it like it was on fire like that like
all the early leads like tens of
thousands of people right would
and and then we like so they had a
desire to kind of grade their website
and so
for your list for the listening audience
one thing i will say is um the power of
building a diagnostic
tool for your industry is immense right
this is the thing that so
website greater was not the solution so
it's not like a freemium thing it's like
oh we're giving you a lightweight
version of hubspot
it was a thing that made you realize you
needed hubspot and that was super
valuable and that can be done in any
industry whether you're in software or
not it's like okay i'm going to
help you determine whether you have a
problem or not because the natural thing
when you do a website where it's like oh
i got a 23 out of 100.
that sucks right i can help like here's
what we do um
or even just like read these blog posts
and you can watch these videos uh it's
so it's
it's work so i'm obsessed with kind of
grading an assessment
um and you folks you guys had a an
episode
like 10 20 episodes ago um around
like quizzes and things like that so one
thing people are so if you do build a
diagnostic tool the one thing and this
is i've learned several lessons but one
of the key ones
is that relative scores work so website
grader from its early days like okay so
if i give you an 87
with that 87 actually means is that
whatever
calculations we're doing behind the
scenes this particular score you
rated better than 87 oh 87 of the 800
000 or whatever the number was websites
we've graded
people love that it's like oh that's
just that kind of relative score versus
an absolute one makes a big difference a
percentile score matters a lot to people
it's like oh
right like i [__] i'm in the bottom ten
percent or the top ten percent of them
are awesome
anyway are you uh sean do you see his
list of ideas
let's just start banging them out i to i
like it so this is two things so first i
think
the thing you just described is like a
growth hack without saying uh yeah i did
it to grow thank you like solved your
own itch
but like that's just we've talked about
it for quizzes quizzes the same thing
lead gen
this is an amazing lead gen tool where
you basically got a bunch of qualified
leads
uh people who self you know they self
assess i have might have a problem they
go get it checked up
your digital doctor said yep you indeed
do have a problem and then all you had
to do is prescribe a solution called
hubspot you know
here's a little i've got a little bottle
for you yeah
tell you how clueless i was back then so
i put this thing up there
um and at the time uh we we had a
meeting set up with gail goodman who was
the ceo of constant contact at that time
and she later
joined up spot board but we met with her
we're like oh we're working on this
company called hubspot it's kind of
related to constant contact space um
we want to get her advice and i showed
her website graders like oh here's what
we do and we can kind of look at
websites whatever
and and she loved it and then she's you
know you might consider putting like an
email address box
because we had no way of knowing who
these people were they were not they
were not linked for us we had
like a hundred thousand people like use
the tools unintentionally
i never thought to collect an email
address like oh wouldn't it be nice to
anyway let me obviously fix that uh but
so i like that and then also for this
uh conversational thing i think what you
just said like we kind of it's kind of
like
sometimes guests on this podcast say
something in passing that i'm like whoa
whoa whoa that's actually a really big
idea
uh and i think you actually said two i
think that the crypto linkedin one is a
big idea and i think the second one
is this idea that if you think about one
of the
biggest and what some people say is the
best business they've ever seen is
google right
people come in there it's just a search
box it's magic genie
if you go ask a question and it tries to
give you some answers and
um the way i view this is if somebody
could actually do this this is sort of
like next level google where
uh i ask it any question and it and it
doesn't just give me like
a list of pages where the answer might
be it's like it actually gives me the
answer
and so um this might be you know in the
business context might be like a
business google but
there's many versions of this uh i don't
know if you've seen this have you ever
seen
uh d build we've checked out this
website yeah we talked about d building
my friend sharif
uh there's a perfect example of a magic
trick thing he um was messing around
with gpt3 so gp3 new technology comes
out
he gets access right away he drops his
whole startup starts just hacking on
this thing at night right
and uh he throws up this he has this
idea of like dude
uh you know squarespace wix this website
builder's been around forever
um great everybody wants to be able to
code without having to code but like
even now it's still so complicated even
after webflow after all this stuff
and um so he's like why can't you just
describe like you know
i want a website that's got like kind of
like two columns and on the left
i want pictures of like places you can
stay and on the right i want the price
of the other thing and you could
literally just type that in
and it'll build you a website that looks
like airbnb like it'll build
a website that does that he posted on
twitter
a gift he's like you know i'm messing
around with gpt3 and watch this
like um you know build a website with a
photo and then add a paypal button but
then make it where the paypal button can
only take five dollars uh
max and like that's it and then send
send the payments to this
and then it like spit out a website that
was that did that like the html and the
css that did that
and he posted that gif and i think off
basically one tweet with one gif he
raised like two million dollars
instantly from like
really smart people when that tweet went
viral because they were like oh
you just showed me a magic trick and uh
i don't know what the company is here
and i think he still doesn't know what
the company is but
um go go down this path and uh see what
you can find
it was pretty amazing i remember when
that tweet went live i mean i i
i i it went viral right away yeah right
i
played with gpt3 uh played with it for a
while across
multiple things it's it's like the
closest
thing to like magic that in turn
it's weird because it's it's kind of a
different vector right because it
originally
is like a text generation mechanism to
be able to write you know pros based on
because it's got this corpus of of data
behind the scenes um
and it's and i talked to sal malton the
ceo brian i had a
he's gracious enough to give us some
time to it's like okay well like where
is this headed what's going on to see
the
impacts on hubspot um in the world in
general and it's like
that's one of those things that i right
now i don't think
quite there to be able to like implement
like practical use cases to actually do
the thing that uh people are trying to
do and i've played with it on
kind of multiple fronts but it's one of
those that it's going to go from a peter
like from a zero to a one very very
quickly it's like all of a sudden that
wasn't really possible and didn't really
quite work
well enough and then it's gonna be like
holy crap then there's like the
uh kind of post gpt3 world what's that
phrase where it's like you know slowly
slowly then all of a sudden or something
like that
yeah it looks like it's gonna be that uh
sam you said you liked some of the ideas
on this list or some of the topics let's
just
we just talked about something huge that
was a huge idea let's talk about
something small but still cool so
it looks like did you buy
remoteculture.com i did
okay so that's a no-brainer there's a
business that will make a million
dollars a year remote culture online
community for those building remote
cultures
easy right that's a no-brainer what
would you do there
i would start a community uh for
remoteculture.com this is okay i'm gonna
do a blog i'm gonna do a paid community
and it's going to be targeted at people
ops and hr people around the world
that need to kind of figure out the new
kind of new world order right we're not
going to try and sell them software
we're just going to connect them to each
other and you and i'm a big
big believer in these kind of
communities and network-based businesses
um because they're efficient in terms of
take that much
you gotta get to critical mass that's
fine but um i think this one would work
it's it's uh
it's a community that's necessary at
this moment in time that hasn't existed
because it hasn't needed to
now it does um and i'm sure there's
people out there doing it but
money helps you can actually build
something yeah there's one on here that
i really like
uh speed round so uh
so by the way this is these are what
these are domains that like you don't
have uh
by the way when i have like a an idea
that's enough in my head
that's like okay well this is kind of
cool i don't like write it down a
notebook i go find a related domain
um it's like it costs 15 if it hasn't
been taken yet or
right or maybe i'll spend more if it's
you know um something really kind of
strikes my fancy what's what's the most
expensive
ideas what's the most expensive domain
you own
well um i haven't had them valued i
don't really sell domains
i own birmingham alabama.com i live
there i think that's probably
the seven figure uh domain just bought
humanism.com and humanism.org
you also bought bought one for me bought
one for you i bought the hustle.com for
you as a
gift that i'm gonna give to you on the
podcast so
you don't care about domain names all
that much no hold on a deal trophy right
uh whenever you get acquired they have
this little tro i don't know sam did you
know about this deal trophies
no i want a deal trophy so when we got
acquired they gave us like
it took like a few months but it was
like hey uh sorry i meant to give this
to you like you know when the deal
closed but i guess it's like
in the deal-making world i'm not i'm not
like a mover and shaker of biz dev
and like corp dev and things like that
but i guess it is sort of a tradition of
when the deals close it's sort of like
the the
champagne what you do is you you get
sort of like a little ornament that has
some
meaning to the deal like in our case our
code name uh was like project whatever
it was like let's just call it uh um
project sharp it wasn't we were i think
we were project h
or something and so then they got like
this like kind of like cool looking
knife uh you know because it's like
project sharp whatever here's the here's
the
the deal trophy so i think your deal
trophy is this domain here well
and and for the record darmesh if you
like gift that to the hustle
company we would love it and i actually
do like domain names my whole point
about domain names was
it's don't let it stop you 99 of people
are not like you are not like me like we
do [__]
like you're killing it and you just made
this little
rinky ding project called growth bot
like that done we do [__] 99 of people
don't do [__] and they have stupid
excuses
like well i don't have the domain name
it's taken or i do have the domain name
therefore i should do that my point is
don't let it stop you but i still think
it's sick and it's awesome and i love it
it's like saying like
just because you don't just because you
don't have a sick gym doesn't mean you
can't go out there and walk and lose
weight
i think uh you know like justin was on
the podcast last time and he was like
um there should be a dating app that
matches you on like kind of your credit
card spending history or something like
that
uh for me that's what it's like with
this podcast where it's like if i just
if you just tell me how many domains you
own that you actually you bought
but you you don't have like a live
project on if that number is you know
greater than 10
we're gonna be we're gonna be thick as
thieves and like you know how many tabs
do you have open right now if i just
knew those two things i can kind of tell
you if this podcast is a fit for you or
not
if you're somebody who owns zero domains
then you probably aren't gonna
you know really connect with this
podcast in a major way i don't think one
and i'd like i'm going to pull a biology
here as uh i'm going to push that
conversation on stack but one thing i
want to make sure
i get out there because it's on the list
of things just you're talking about
ideas um it's like how do you assess
ideas how do you think about ideas i
know sean you love frameworks and you do
too sam
um here's a simple one in terms of like
assessing
whether you're doing it for yourself or
you're investing whatever it is and i'll
tell you the common mistake um
so the three things i look at are
like profit potential like if this thing
went exactly as planned as the founders
envisioned
what could it be like let's just assume
all things like all the stars align
everything works the way you expect it
to and it goes what could it be what's
the overall potential for the project
uh what kind of like passion do you have
around it it's like okay are you excited
about it or not excited about it
um and the third one is uh around the
probability of that success that you
that you want right and i i'm a quant
based guy so i'll take each of those
factors
with 0 10 square and multiply them
together and i'll get a score out of a
thousand right and you can put the
weighting differently it's like oh i
care more about passion than
you know uh the profit potential or
something else but the common mistake
people make is that they will
look at the probability of success first
and almost exclusively as the
high order bit filter it's like oh i had
this idea but the likelihood is like
0.01
that that's actually going to work and
so i'm not even going to think about
what the potential could have been or
how passionate i may or may not be about
it and then they just kind of discard
the idea
i think that is statistically unwise and
an impractical move and here's why is
that
the way you should be looking at ideas
is you kind of take the profit potential
like here's the possible outcome
multiply this it's the ev
the expected value statistically of this
thing it's like oh i have a one percent
chance
at a billion dollars the expected value
is one percent of a billion dollars
that's the value of that particular
thing
um and so you shouldn't discard
something just because the probability
is low because it may have a
disproportionately high
potential that makes it more interesting
than it would otherwise um so that's the
like be a little bit more structured
about how you assess things that people
throw things away too easily because
in the second note hard one lessons good
ideas are
dangerous and they're dangerous because
what you want to find are the great
ideas uh right that's the thing you can
kind of get behind you don't have to
find them before you start the company
we can talk about that
um so bad ideas are easy to find that's
just a bad idea
good idea masquerade is great ideas and
it's hard to tell them apart and they're
the ones that end up kind of
spinning a bunch of cycles for you and
it's like okay well it ended up being
good but just it's
um yeah failure's not a problem like
mediocrity is a thing everybody should
be fearful of it's like just get it out
there try and see what happens but uh
anyway
and but the big problem because it
wastes the most valuable resource it
wastes time
right because it's not gonna die quickly
nor is it gonna take off so it is a
slow long burn uh at a mediocre level
and so you're sort of locking in over a
period of time a mediocre
outcome and that's what mediocrity is
the biggest difference i think the
hardest about bootstrap companies
especially uh tech companies that have a
low kind of
capital need is they can actually live
forever
and not go anywhere right because it
doesn't take that much stuff it's like
okay you've got an aws instance
somewhere that's costing you
it doesn't really cost that much um and
you don't have investors pushing on you
to say oh we need some sort of outcome
and so you can run that company
indefinitely and waste a bunch of your
time
when the next idea that you could have
done was sitting right behind it right
like i have
i've talked to hundreds of entrepreneurs
by this point i have never
ever in my entire life met an
entrepreneur that had just one idea
so i go you will have more dude it's
like okay and you know try the thing
if you can sell the thing sell the thing
if you're not that excited about it or
or
you just want to cash out take some
chips off the table there's uh no harm
and no shame um but
yeah did you do but you guys didn't
raise a significant amount at hubspot
did you uh 105 million
money before in public yeah i'm supposed
to say classic
venture-backed playbook company it's
like there's nothing
and intentionally so that seems
interesting to me because you don't see
you seem like a guy who likes freedom
and
um knows that he's knows what he is and
knows that he's a little bootstrapper
that's what he's trying to do
i'll i'll tell you the exact
conversation we had so when brian i
started this
one things we were firmly agreed on is
that we didn't want
i'm not a baseball or a sports person
but like we didn't want a single or a
double hit right like we wanted to like
swing for the fences and
either this we we do this and we're good
at every point that we have a decision
to make a fork in the road we
are going to take the one that gives us
a higher chance of being the spectacular
outcome
even if that means we're possibly going
to go down and crashing burning flames
right and so
was was was brian uh was he successful
like you were or was he
he hadn't had like an exit because he
was uh he hadn't done a startup before
this was his first one um
but he also was like okay this is my
last swing at bat right this is the i'm
not
this is it this is the one that's either
gonna do it or not gonna do it um
and so that that was the reason it's
like we weren't worried about diluting
we
negotiate the fairest value we could we
made sure the terms were meaningful had
good investors but we were not worried
about
what our percentage taken the company
was and how that moved over time we're
like okay if this thing
does what it needs to do uh the
valuation and all that and the
equity dilution will not matter like on
the margin it just it
it's we want it to be a binary outcome
either it's going to be this huge
massive thing
which um will change our lives uh and
have a massive impact or it goes down
and crashing burning flames which is
highly likely but um we weren't looking
to hold on to control we weren't looking
at this like we wanted to be
we didn't want to be king we want to be
rich i guess when you're doing like
ideation and stuff though
you you either i think you wrote you
wrote it here
you're down with starting some a project
with a bad idea
because you're quite confident that
you'll you can figure out you can make
it great
as you get into it right my
general advice is and this is not just
you know my personal kind of
uh lived experience as the new folks
would say having talked to entrepreneurs
and
kind of looking at the history of them
so many of them the thing that we know
them for now is not the
the idea they originally started with
like there are a handful of cases where
yeah when exactly the plan this is what
it was and and
often the case is that you will not find
the great idea until after you start
your company
until after you start having contact
with customers and actually trying to do
the thing
if you sit on the sidelines trying to
assess ideas and look at market metrics
and things like that and
it's like you're just never going to get
started that's the kind of wannabe
entrepreneurs that will kind of analyze
it to death it's like
you wouldn't even know what a good idea
was it's hard to tell these things until
you actually try something it's uh
just yeah it and try it um where do we
go from here sean we got uh
i think we think we got a rap but here
there's this i think we have to have you
on again if you're down because
here's five topics i want to hear about
uh why i don't play golf and what i do
instead
uh i want that one why i hate
inefficiency in markets
uh why i don't believe in karma but i
believe in extended feedback loops
uh sometimes faking it is making it uh
introverted
engineers guide for public speaking like
i need i need all of these so we may
have to do another one um
i have one question i want to wrap with
in this one uh which is
you seem like a a pretty astute guy like
you're
very very good observations and i think
you you you know kind of who we are and
what we care about and that we would
value honestly so i'm curious you can
ask me the intro question aren't you
you can ask me the intro question no no
not the intro question that that sam
sam's trying to get all the interest he
can ask you that one i want to know i'm
i'm trying to make the content great so
what would be the most uh fair criticism
you could give us on the podcast what's
your critique of the podcast
um for you as a listener and there's
like
you can offend you can exactly that's
kind of what i'm taking you up for say
whatever it is whatever you truly feel
all right um
so partly i think you have to recognize
that you guys are multi-channel so
you're kind of solving for the audio
format i know you have the youtube
videos and things like that
but the one tactical thing that you
should fix like next week or the week
after
is you should apply the sean 25
headlines thing
for headlines for every podcast episode
like what's the one nugget that's going
to cause people to want to listen to
that episode
even if they're not subscribed when they
see it in their youtube feed and youtube
recommends it's like oh
right why this successful entrepreneur
never played golf and
you shouldn't either whatever it is
right exactly i'm on uh
i'm i'm taking notes keep going if you
do that my
my guess is that the click-through rate
goes up because you can't not
um right now you just kind of identify
the episode number and who the guest is
or whatever
there's no real maybe the topic area but
right now me and sam don't even
want people to click me and sam don't
even touch the headlines when dan does
it
i don't even know i see a notification
it goes out and i think i judge the
headline myself i'm like ah
that's not gonna give very many clicks
or oh that's a juicy one that'll work
i i say give dan a free pass to the um
the sean copyright report
of course yesterday that's awesome
okay what else you got anything else of
course you have more
who me yeah yeah what about more that
was a weak criticism yeah that was an
easy one okay um
this is a hard one right um is around
he's gonna say like just change your
voice like your
face is great but i suppose
it's yours so it's around the
it's around the brand and this is the
hardest thing for an entrepreneur to
kind of reconcile with
so a couple of issues that i have as a
amateur branding person is that anything
that can be reduced an acronym will be
which
my first million is often reduced to
that uh and then you kind of lose the
punch because when it comes down to an
acronym anyone that comes
like immediately they're not going to
know what it is if they don't know what
it is and there's some value to that but
it doesn't compensate for the kind of
opportunity you have so that's one thing
is acronyms not good uh but the other
one
is that the kind of my first million
there is a
cadre caterer however that word is
pronounced of people that will directly
res
that topic will resonate with like oh i
want to learn about that
but i think your reach is much wider now
and there are people
there are probably more people outside
that fear that that particular like okay
well
it's fine that it's about that but
really the reason i'm here is to hear
folks like biology right like that
and that episode which is i think one of
the best epos episodes you've had
had nothing to do with the first million
anything it had to do with big ideas
we i actually agree with you and we've
had this conversation the problem that
we had was like [__] we're pretty deep
into it we can't change
yep yep i i for what it's worth i think
we should change
just because i hate the name so i don't
really care about the brand equity i'm
just sort of like
i don't want to have a thing i don't
yeah i don't i don't love it i really
don't it's
i don't i don't love the name i don't
like the name of the hustle either
if you believe that this thing is going
to get 10 times bigger in the future
which i do
then 90 of our future listeners haven't
even heard about us yet and so
uh we're we're only offending a very
small we're only changing on a very
small population of people
for the good of the long run that would
be my my and by the way if you think
it's hard now
you realize the direction you're headed
it does not get easier right it's going
to get harder and harder
like a year from now two years from now
five years from now it's like ah like
should we have changed this like
what would have been it's like not that
it's gonna have a dramatic impact on the
numbers or anything but
on the margin these things matter and
they kind of uh accrue to accumulate
time
and here's what i would do to make life
easier for yourselves
um don't decide to change the name
decide to come up with alternatives
and then objectively measure those
alternatives like okay am i willing to
give up the brand equity and go through
the
the pain of changing a name because this
one is just so much better
if something clicks for you great but
make an honest concerted effort to come
up with those alternatives and options
and then you can still decide like yeah
these are better but they're just
marginally better they're not better
enough to go through the headache of
trying to change it
right that would be my advice okay
that's great uh sam you want anything
else before we go
we're going to follow up with some
intros my man we got dan
dan do we have an update are we reaching
out to guests can we we got to use
darmesh she knows everyone
well i'm curious actually you do know
everybody who's awesome who's like
particularly awesome that you're just
like
either kind of underrated or you're just
so you know what i don't know as many
people as you think like i'm kind of on
the
internet did i do things but i you know
i don't like i don't leave my house
right it's like
it's like you have to in order to kind
of be that person you have to sort of
like
interact with carbon based life forms in
real life right like i don't do that
that's not a thing i do
so it's hard to kind of build those
kinds of relationships but i would on
your list i would have um so i'm not
going to be good at intros but i like
naval would be awesome to have on the
podcast uh he's like a
like that kind of biology level uh
thinker i think he'd be awesome the
audience
would love him so that would be great
great we'll take that intro thank you
yeah he doesn't know me i mean he knows
me like loosely
i'm gonna start calling you uh we'll
call you uncle darmesh you gotta pick it
up
i'm willing to try it don't don't get me
wrong those qualms about trying to make
the intro just don't uh demand your
expectations it's like well i thought
like darmesh actually could like swing
things and make [__] happen
anyone else someone i do know that i
think would be good on the podcast
drew from dropbox i know really well so
that's an intro i could make um
what's up yeah that would be a good one
i heard he's an amazing singer is that
true he's he's uh
he's a good singer for a founder amazing
founder is what i mean
legit he's legit um so darmesh
darmash sean was pretty nervous coming
up to this because he was like well i
just like to over prepare and i don't
think good on my feet or
sorry you're like i i you know i prepare
i and i don't love like just making [__]
up
i think you did an excellent job dan has
been texting me saying darmesh is so
awesome
i told you darmash i go i told you this
yesterday i'm going to predict the
future
you're going to come on and then you're
going to start wanting to come on like
once a month maybe
i have a feeling that that we have just
accomplished that and that's going to be
true
you're freaking awesome um what's your
twitter handle it's just darmaso
d-h-a-r-m-e-s-h
you're you're really active so people
want to get in touch with everywhere
linkedin twitter
facebook pick your thing anything you
wanna
you want to pimp out or promote no i'm
not a promoter kind of guy
that's not my thing but well thanks man
this is awesome we um
i talked to you a lot i got to set up i
want to set up like time to just holler
at you because i i want to learn about
you more i want to learn about hubs
sam wants to be your first direct report
in 15 years no no no no i don't want to
i don't want that but uh this is great
heaton was like you got to learn from
dharmesh just learn what makes hubspot
tick so uh thanks dude this is awesome
we're gonna have you back on
did it did it turn out as good as you
thought i love you guys this was this
was fun
this was i yeah and i say it's it's more
importantly i hope it
ends up being useful for the audience
that's the thing i'm solving for
honestly i'm looking at this doc i feel
like we left a lot on the table we have
a lot more that we could do i'm sort of
regretting uh you kind of have to i
always feel this way with a guest by the
way i'm like
the first 20 minutes were slow but it's
also like i've never brought this person
and like you know the audience doesn't
know all about this person so there is a
certain context building that has to
happen
yeah you got a date i never figure out
why every every single guest i'm like oh
the first 25 minutes were slow but then
it got really good
and um yeah i don't know if that's just
my own
i'm just kicking myself for for no
reason or if other people feel that way
maybe we should actually do something
different and like
sort of pull the future forward like
pull just start at the start at that uh
25 minute mark basically this is final
folks that's uh
yeah all right that's a wrap
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back